is it really that insane to think that i
can land a plane experts from a
university in new zealand yes it's a
real country
found that men were more confident than
women in their ability to land a plane
after watching a single how-to youtube
video
you know i used to feel the same way
after watching open heart surgery videos
on medical websites
but that's a lot harder than it looks
just ask my uncle steve
you can't rip steve
now although both sexes were
overconfident men rated their confidence
12 points higher out of a hundred than
women did you know of course that's math
so we already lost half the audience
a sexist might say
but it all makes sense after all if
women were busy landing the plane who
would bring me my drinks and pretzels
another sexist might say a meaner one
god there's sexists everywhere tyrus
it's this place is filled with them
there's also apparently races to go with
sexist because this is a white thing
we don't leave our seats we sit next to
emergency exit and try to time our way
out you guys the the front of the plane
hits first no brother's going to the
front right so we'll let the the
dad of five like g willikers i'm gonna
go let you go ahead bruh i'm gonna stay
back here with your wife and
enjoy myself before we all go out so
it's a no but wait a minute that doesn't
answer the question i want to know i'm
telling you no black man in his right
mind is going to volunteer to go to the
front of the plane okay not happening
that is
you guys win all right that's yours
i never saw that coming and maybe buck
you know you were saying that in the
green room that's where he got it from
no i'm kidding
isn't landing a plane
what thinks you've got kicked off
platforms before like the players just
crashed and i'm the only person on it
a plane no different than landing a
plane on a computer let's be honest i
mean
you see all those bikes i played flight
simulator back in the day i feel like
you know you get your air speed you
figure it out but you know it's i feel
like the ladies would probably do better
at this parallel parking the plane might
be more difficult oh another sexist
might say
douglas i am disgusted by the amount of
sexism on display here
thank god you and i are both like
straight as they come
[Laughter]
is it just that men are cockier
uh i do understand this this problem uh
men are and men are prone to this but
then a lot of people are look at the
remember the heimlich maneuver the one
where you're meant to grab somebody like
just in a restaurant whenever anyone
coughs everyone wants to hide like for
them because that's the one thing they
know okay it's the same with um what
i've heard some years ago there was
there was a medical thing where everyone
they're always tracheotomies remember
somebody gets like stung by a bee and
then they and then they swell up and
they attract you to me apparently in um
i remember in england
the ambulance people said
beware members of the public who don't
know what they're talking about coming
over and saying you've got a
drachioctomy yes because they've just
seen it a lot on television exactly so
we do think we're experts when we've
just seen it on the box yeah and uh best
not to try to land a plane or track i
used to volunteer to do cpr all the time
but you know
the sores
cat
what do you think of this more sexism
more overconfident men could you land a
plane
no
no okay but i also like i do feel this
way when i watch um people do food
challenges though right i'm like i could
eat an 800 ounce bowl of ramen and i
really think i can like if i don't take
my vivants i get really hungry i could
just not take my vivants and eat 800
ounces of ramen i mean also what kind of
plate what kind of plane are we talking
about that should be i don't know if
that was it this is the story
i'm just saying a single single guy that
would say that right
exactly this is because there's meant to
be a button now you just press and it
lands automatically
one of those problems i thought it was
yeah and i bet you thought the beatles
weren't that great yeah yeah oh shots
fired up
i think about that every time i look at
you
sexist and anti-beetles anti-beetles
and apparently stealing my black jokes
[Laughter]
it's quite a catalogue of crime it
really is it is are we going to a
commercial service
show it's almost over don't go away
we'll be right back